ja die erste Frage an den
bundeswirtschaftsministern Robert
habbeck das Bundesverfassungsgericht wir
haben es gerade gehört hat die ja die
wie soll man sagen die Umetikettierung
der coronahilfen für nicht gesetzesmäßig
erklärt eine Klage der Union hat dazu
geführt und die einfache Frage wie
konnte es dazu
kommen es ist so dazu gekommen dass die
Auffassung die politische aber auch die
juristische in den Ministerien war dass
man einen Krisenfall der in einem Jahr
passiert und der aber fortwirkt und
Maßnahmen Nachsicht zieht die in dem
Jahr nicht abgearbeitet werden in einem
Form mit einem
Beschluss bearbeiten kann also ich mache
ein Beispiel das sozusagen verwandt ist
es gibt auch ein flutopferfond oder ein
nothilfefond dass die Katastrophe jetzt
in diesem Fall im ahal ist in einem Jahr
passiert aber natürlich dauert es länger
Brücken Häuser und so weiter zu erneuern
und trotz trzdem wurde jetzt nicht immer
wieder der Notfall ausgerufen oder
hergestellt das hat einfach länger
gedauert und so war die Überlegung
Anfang der Legislatur Corona war vorbei
die deutsche Wirtschaft war aber noch
nicht wieder robust genug da wir nutzten
das Geld für weitere
Schritte war ihn klar her habe dass es
möglicherweise nicht ganz klar ist sie
haben ebenw was interessantes gesagt sie
sagten gerade
da hatten wir Fachleute da hatten wir
Beamte da hatten wir Menschen die das
für zulässig
befunden haben ich habe hier was ganz
anderes vorliegen schon im Januar
2022 sagt der Bundesrechnungshof in
einer Stellungnahme für den
Haushaltsausschuss folgenden Satz die
Zuweisung von 60 Milliarden Euro an den
Energie und klimafond erscheint unter
mehreren Aspekten verfassungsrechtlich
zweifelhaft das war 222 und im August 23
und dann bezogen auf die 200 Milliarden
sagt der Bundesrechnungshof der der
Bundesrechnungshof hat zu jeder Facette
des vom bundesverfanz
Bundesfinanzministeriums gewählten
Vorgehens Achtung erhebliche Bedenken
das heißt da gab es ganz klare Warnungen
und bevor sie antworten vielleicht hen
wir noch mal ganz kurz selber rein sie
selber hatten im Juni des vergangenen
Jahres ebenfalls so eine Ahnung dass das
möglicherweise schiefgehen könnte es
wenige Monate her war diesen diesen
Sommer beim Juni diesen Jahres wir haben
eine Herausforderung bei der
energieintensiven Industrie Stahl Chemie
Grundstoffindustrie und da wiederum
würde ich tatsächlich sagen schider ist
dem Standort wie übrigens auch der
wärmewende dass die Union im Moment
gegen die Gelder die dafür reserviert
sind klagt das in der Tat würde bedeuten
dass uns der Fußboden weggezogen wird
auf dem wir versuchen die
wirtschaftliche Situation in Deutschland
Stab zu stabilisieren wenn diese Klage
erfolgreich ist das würde Deutschland
wirklich wirtschaftspolitisch hart hart
treffen wahrscheinlich so hart dass wir
das nicht bestehen werden das ist ein
wahnsinnssatz also in in zwei teilen das
erste ist man hat das Gefühl sie selber
ahnen das könnte schiefgehen und das
zweite ist sie sagen wenn das schief
geheht dann wird uns das so hart treffen
dass wir uns davon nicht mehr
erholen nun erst einmal dieser ganze
Komplex der Schuldenbremse und ihrer
Auslegung ist ja bisher noch nie
durchgeklagt oder durchgeurteilt worden
insofern gab es verschiedene Stimmen so
oder so und aber noch keine juristische
Bezugsgröße die haben wir jetzt vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht bekommen jetzt
herrscht Klarheit dass die
Schuldenbremse im deutschen Grundgesetz
sehr streng
sehr fundamental ist und auch so
ausgelegt werden muss zurecht da war
natürlich aber
trotzdem das hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht unser höchstes
Gericht so entschieden und das Recht das
es spricht ist das Recht in der
Bundesrepublik
Deutschland trotzdem ist der zweite Teil
auch richtig wir sind in einer
krisenhaften Situation ich würde sagen
in einer Po Krise verschiedene Krisen
überlagern sich als die Regierung
angefangen hat noch immer die
Nachwirkung der coronapandemie also der
Tiefe wirtschaftlicher Einbruch dann kam
die energiekrisen dazu dann kam die
instabile Weltlage dazu auch
Absatzmärkte haben sich anders
entwickelt oder sind nicht wie
eigentlich erwartet stark China als
Beispiel dazu kommt ein
hochwettbewerbskompetitives Umfeld dass
wir so gar nicht kennen die anderen
großen
Wirtschaftsräume subventionieren massiv
für den Aufbau der der nächsten Phase
der industriellen Produktion das heißt
das Land die Energie die Industrie des
Landes steht massiv unter Druck und vor
diesem Hintergrund unabhängig jetzt von
der
Rechtssprechung ist die Lage schon
ohnehin angespannt ja um in dieser Lage
die wirtschaftliche Substanz
Deutschlands zu schützen
weiterzuentwickeln den Wohlstand zu
erneuern Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen
Regionen zu stabilisieren haben wir
diese Gelder gut brauchen können und das
ist ja das Problem für dem wir jetzt
stehen jetzt sind sie erst einmal weg
und wir müssen an anderen Stellen andere
Summen oder ähnliche Summen auftreiben
damit dieses Projekt das ist ja noch
immer notwendig und richtig nämlich die
Stabilisierung der deutschen Wirtschaft
in diesem feindlichen Umfeld dass wir
das irgendwie hinbekommen können noch
mal hier geht's äh um richtig was
man möchte fast sagen sehr historisch um
einen bekannten deutschen Bundeskanzler
mal zu zitieren äh 60 Milliarden die
ökologische Transformation eines ganzen
Landes der zweite Fond 200 Milliarden um
Gaspreis und Strompreis und so weiter zu
subventionieren ebenfalls mittlerweile
gesperrt ein ganzes Land das Massiv
verunsichert ist wir haben sie gerade
gehört sie hatten im Juni schon eine
Idee davon wie das ausgehen könnte Frau
from die hier bei uns ist hat es
ebenfalls schon sehr früh gesagt und
sagte macht das nicht das ist keine gute
Idee Frau Grimm entschuldigung habe ich
Frau from gesagt Entschuldigung Frau
Grimm die bei uns
ist und jetzt hat man das Gefühl sie
sind kalt davon erwischt worden gibt es
einen Plan B wie haben sie mit dem
Finanzminister wie haben sie mit dem
Bundeskanzler sich darüber
ausgetauscht ich komme gleich zu dem
Plan B oder zu der Bewältigung der
Situation aber ich würde gerne noch
einmal deutlich machen dass die 60
Milliarden die staatlichen Ausgaben sind
die Summe die sie auslösen sollen die
Investition ist ja xfach größer das wird
Stefan weil gleich wenn er möchte aus
Niedersachsen erzählen können es soll ja
Investitionen von Industrie oder von
Unternehmen anregen auch private
Investition also die Summe die der
deutschen Volkswirtschaft fehlt ist viel
größer als die 60 Milliarden die sind ja
nur sozusagen der Kickoff der stat für
weitere Investitionen und dann muss man
ebenfalls verstehen weil das am Anfang
als das Urteil da war
fast so ein bisschen verlächerlich
gemacht wurde also als wäre es irgendwie
eine ein jetzt ein orchideenproblem dass
wir im Land haben mit diesen
Investitionen werden Arbeitsplätze
geschaffen oder gehalten werden Regionen
stabilisiert auf diese Investition
setzen ganze Betriebszweige die dann
wieder Aufträge generieren für den
Maschinenbau für die Handwerker und die
Handwerker und die Maschinenbauer die
kaufen Brötchen die Reisen die gehen in
Restaurants also genau geht tief in die
wirtschaftliche Substanz der deutschen
Wirtschaft rein nur dass man einmal klar
hat worüber man redet es geht nicht
darum dass man irgendeineer Haltung so
oder so zum Klimaschutz haben kann und
dann ist es halt ein bisschen weniger es
geht darum dass in dieser in dieser
angestrengten Situation unter der das
Land steht jetzt die Möglichkeiten
massiv geschwächt sind vorläufig erst
einmal geschwächt sind sich daraus zu
arbeiten oder sich dagegen zu wehren so
und natürlich gibt es Vorbereitung aber
das Urteil ist lang und die Begründung
ist lang wir hatten heute die Anhörung
im im Haushaltsausschuss also lauter
Experten haben noch mal ihre Sicht
dargestellt wir sind weit
fortgeschritten in den
Haushaltsberatungen und das muss jetzt
alles zusammengebracht werden das ist
natürlich nicht ganz trivial deswegen
macht es Sinn die Lösung hinter den
Kulissen vorzubereiten und nicht Herr
LAN sie werden es mir nachsehen in
Talkshows Ideen vielleicht schon
Vorschläge die kommentiert sind auch die
vielleicht schon verworfen sind hier
auszubereiten sondern das in Ruhe und
konzentriert abzuarbeiten aber ich will
kein Hill daraus machen mein Anliegen
ist mein mein Projekt ist es möglichst
große Anteile dessen was wir uns
vorgenommen haben und was ich für
zentral wichtig halte auch nach wie vor
zu realisieren so genau sie haben es
gerade gesagt und ich verstehe das
völlig wenn sie sagen in in irgendeiner
Talkshow wollen sie das nicht so zum
Besten geben das ist aber heute hier ein
bisschen mehr ich finde dass die
deutsche Öffentlichkeit durch us ein
Anrecht hätte mal zu erfahren und her
weil hat gerade so mit dem Kopf
genickt ich glaube die Leute sollten
vielleicht mal hören ob es tatsächlich
eine Idee gibt einen Plan B gibt
zumindest eine Andeutung in welche
Richtung die Reise am Ende geht woher
sollen diese vielen Milliarden kommen
einsparen geht ja schlecht bei der
Summe na ja das ich war ja häufig genug
bei Ihnen und dann haben sie mich
gefragt wieso wie können sie sich
eigentlich immer so so dumm streiten die
ampelreg
und jetzt in der Tat es ist eine zesur
das würde ich auch so beschreiben eine
zesur für die deutsche Wirtschafts und
damit auch
Arbeitsmarktpolitik an der vieles hängt
der die Strukturstabilität in Regionen
die sehr stark betroffen sind von von
neuen von neuen Herausforderungen aber
auch natürlich die Voraussetzungen die
wir schaffen müssen um klimaneutral zu
werden und Klimaneutralität mit der
Erneuerung unseres Wohlstandes zu
verbinden also vielleicht darf ich daran
auch erinner dass das gleiche
Bundesverfassungsgericht vor ungefähr 2
Jahren geurteilt hat dass der
Klimaschutz ebenfalls eine Verpflichtung
der Politik ist quasi Verfassungsrang
hat und diese beiden Urteile sie sind
jetzt beide da und sie sind nicht so
ganz leicht zueinander zu bringen da
muss jetzt also eine politische Arbeit
erfolgen so was ich sagen kann ist dass
es den festen Vorsatz gibt diese Arbeit
auch abzuleisten obwohl die Gelder jetzt
erst einmal fehlen wie wir es tun das
werden sie na die Technik die werden wir
dann vorstellen wenn wir uns auf eine
oder verschiedene Maßnahmen geeinigt
haben aber so viel politische Klugheit
hat jeder alles was man öffentlich
erzählt kommt viel sehr viel schwieriger
und deswegen werde ich mich hier daran
nicht beteiligen an den ganzen
Spekulationen und dem Ben und aber aber
das Ziel kann ja nur sein dass wenn wir
die
Wettbewerbssituation also die
Widerstandsfähigkeit der deutschen
Wirtschaft stärken wollen und die
Wettbewerbssituation bestehen wollen
gegenüber den USA und China
wenn wir nicht Regionen oder Unternehmen
und Arbeitsplätze in den Orkus fallilen
lassen wollen dann müssen wir eine
Lösung finden die dem Projekt das wir
mit den 60 Milliarden aufgesetzt haben
entspricht das heißt in Zukunft
Wirtschaft vor Klima was muss hinten
runterfallen wenn wenn all diese
Milliarden plötzlich fehlen was was ist
das worauf sie verzichten
könnten nein aber das wäre der falsche
Gegensatz und das ist ja das worüber ich
die ganze Zeit versuche zu reden wenn
wir die grünen Technologien der Zukunft
einsetzen wollen dann sollten wir sie
möglichst hier entwickeln sie werden ja
kommen es wird Elektrolyse es wird
Wasserstoff es wird eMobilität es wird
Solarpanele und Windkraftanlagen geben
die Frage ist werden die auch hier
produziert und werden Sie mit dem Stahl
produziert der hier produziert wird und
dem Aluminium und so weiter und sofort
das heißt die die die Interpretation
jetzt ist dem Klimaschutz ähm der Zacken
aus der Krone gebrochen worden die ist
im besten Fall ein Viertel richtig weil
natürlich dabei sind auch ein paar
Projekte womit wir jetzt direkte
dekarbonisierungs also
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen finanzieren
Gebäudesanierung etwa aber der Kern des
Problems liegt da drin dass wir die
Techniken also den wohlstandsaufbau die
wohlstandserneuerung hier im Land jetzt
sehr viel schwieriger machen können und
wenn sie sich umhören in den Betrieben
bei den Gewerkschaften bei den
Unternehmensverbänden die Sorge ist
jetzt nicht dass wir weniger Klimaschutz
machen die Sorge ist dass wir all die
Investitionen und die
Wertschöpfungsketten die wir aufbauen
wollen jetzt nicht oder sehr viel
schwieriger tätigen wollen also ein
ökonomisches Problem das jetzt
entstanden ist und das kann man
natürlich heilen also im
klimaschutzbereich kann man heilen sagen
dann kaufen wir eben den Stahl aus weiß
ich nicht aus Indien aber damit ist eben
auch gesagt dass der die Stahlproduktion
in Bremen oder im Saarland nicht
zukunftsfähig gemacht wird und das
können wir wohl nicht ernsthaft wollen
das können wir doch also ich jedenfalls
will das nicht und
deswegen ist der Nordstern den wir uns
ins Schaufenster hängen müssen oder an
dem wir uns orientieren müssen ist zu
sagen wir müssen das nach wie vor
möglich machen jetzt jetzt haben sie
sozusagen das das ganze Dilemma wirklich
umfassend beschrieben s noch mal an dem
Punkt die Frage im Juni diesen Jahres
reden sie so im Bundestag da haben sie
offenbar schon geahnt was auf sie
zukommt wie kann es sein dass man
dermaßen nicht vorbereitet ist auf
dieses Szenario
noch einmal die die politische der
politische Modus wie Wendi dieser
Regierung ist von Anfang an eine Krise
nach der anderen zu bestehen und
abzuarbeiten die Energiekrise covid-19
kriseahn weltpolitischen Lage die Herr
sie haben die Krise geahnt darf ich noch
fragen darf ich noch mal fragen ist ja
auch nicht so dass wir darf ich noch mal
fragen Christian Lindner der Bund der
dan der Bundes auch Ihre Sendung
natürlich der Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner welche Rolle spielt er
dabei sie hätten es sich doch sehr viel
einfacher machen können Herr weilnickt
gerade und ich ahne auch beim Blick zu
Frau Grimm warum sie hätten es sich
einfacher machen können sie hätten ein
weiteres Mal den Notstand ausrufen
können dann hätten sie die
Schuldenbremse umgehen können und dann
hätten sie dieses Geld jetzt dann hätten
sie diese Schulden aufnehmen können ist
es zutreffend dass es die FDP war die
darauf bestanden hat diese
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten und dass wir
deshalb jetzt unter anderem in der
Situation sind in der wir
sind wir treffen Entscheidung als
Regierung gemeinsam und ist nicht die
Antwort auf die Frage ich würde gerne
wissen Entscheidung die war das war das
der explizite W gen die Anwort aber war
das der explizite Wunsch der FDP es
genauso zu
machen es geht darum dass eine Regierung
eine Entscheidung immer gemeinsam
verantwortet und trifft also ja und so
tragen wir diese Konsequenzen jetzt auch
als Regierung gemeinsam und werden auch
gemeinsam Lösung finden also
ja ich habe gesagt die Regierung hat im
Jahr 23 die Schuldenbremse nein die den
Notfall nicht ausgerufen gehabt und das
ist eine gemeinsame Entscheidung der
Regierung
gewesen hinter der sie vollumfänglich ST
per Definition entscheidet per
Definition entscheidet eine Regierung
immer gemeinsam eine Entscheidung hinter
der sie ist keine eine Regierung mehr
hinter der sie gestanden
haben ich will jetzt nicht den
Bundeskanzler zitieren aber ich kann
mich nicht mehr daran
erinnern das sagt ja alles
ähm der der der zweite Punkt der mich
interessieren würde ist nein Herr LZ
Herr LZ es ist egal ich wenn ich das
noch mal aufgreifen darf aber das ist
doch interessant das muss man noch mal
verstehen was die Genese dieser
Geschichte ist und das ist ja nicht
trivial was da passiert ist eine eine
eine tiefe Krise in der wir da gerade
stecken
entscheidend ist vor allem dass wir
rauskommen dass wir jetzt nach vorne
schauen und dass wir nicht nach hinten
gucken sondern versuchen die Dinge jetzt
schnell in Lösung zu überführen und das
ist kompliziert genug sie haben es ja
gesagt 60 Milliarden und das ist ja
sozusagen die kleinste Summe über die
wir reden genau die sind nicht einfach
so zusammenzukratzen und deswegen sind
rückwärts gewandte Debatten die sind
wahrscheinlich für tunistisch
interessant aber sie helfen mir jetzt im
Alltag gar nicht und sie helfen auch den
Unternehmen nicht und sie helfen auch
den Menschen nicht es geht jetzt darum
schnell Lösung zu finden und wenn es
nach mir geht Lösungen die aus den guten
politischen Gründen die ich versucht
habe zu
nennen dazu führen dass wir diese
Investitionen die wir dringend im Land
brauchen aus verschiedenen Gründen
Klimaneutralität Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
und so weiter auch hinbekommen kommen
und deswegen ist die Debatte zurück
keine keine sinnvolle Frau GM wir haben
ja auch als Sendung ein bisschen die
Aufgabe therapeutisch tätig zu sein
gelegentlich ein bisschen
Vergangenheitsbewältigung zu machen
verstehe Herrn habck dass er das jetzt
gerne umgehen möchte würd sie trotzdem
noch mal gerne Fragen auf wessen
Betreiben hin ist nicht der Notstand
ausgerufen worden warum hat man diese
Entscheidung so getroffen das einmal
gerne
verstehen ja also zunächst mal ist das
Urteil natürlich in finanz
finanzpolitischer Wendepunkt und
wahrscheinlich auch ein klimapolitischer
Wendepunkt man hätte für 2023 den
Notstand sicher ausrufen können das wäre
eine Alternative gewesen im Gutachten
des Sachverständigen Rats im November 22
haben wir uns schon dahingehend geäußert
auch im Umfeld das Gutachtens dass man
noch besser den Notstand ausrufen sollte
als diese buchungstricks zu machen wo
wir auch schon nicht ganz sicher waren
es ist einfach nicht vereinbar mit dem
wie man eigentlich das Gesetz
ausgelegt hätte
und das ist aber in der Vergangenheit
häufiger passiert jetzt nicht in dem
Umfang aber es gibt verschiedenste
Sondervermögen die auf die Art befüllt
sind es betrifft den Klima und
transformationsfond betrifft den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond aber es
betri das hei damit die Zuschauer das
Verstehen einmal die 60 Milliarden das
ist die Summe die jetzt sozusagen für
unzulässig erklärt worden ist aber ich
sag dir eben gerade auch der ganz große
Fond die 200 Milliarden ist der zweite
von dem sie sprechen auch der ist
mittlerweile blockiert der habe gesagt
braucht ihr gar nicht zu klagen weil
wissen wir eigentlich schon auch das
wird das Bundesverfassungsgericht
kassieren weil auch der genauso sie
sagen buchungstrick umetikettiert worden
ausd dem auch die energiepreisbremsen
z.B bezahlt werden und jetzt ist es
natürlich so dass für
2023 zu Beginn des Jahres 2023 war es
natürlich so dass gerade da die hohen
Energiepreise bei den Verbrauchern
ankamen deswegen hat man ja die
energiepreisbremsen beschlossen die
waren ja erst 2023 dann wirklich
wirksam und implementiert und insofern
hätte man es auch wahrscheinlich mit
einer Notlage machen können mal die
Frage wer hat das verhindert das hat die
Bundesregierung so beschlossen es war
sicherlich so dass man bedenken hatte
noch mal die
notauslage zu erklären weil man
vielleicht dachte oh dann kommen wir
noch auf alle möglichen Ideen was man da
ausgeben könnte kann
man das war vielleicht ein Argument
warum jetzt das genauso argumentiert
wurde ich war ja nicht Mitglied der
Bundesregierung äh auf jeden Fall ist es
natürlich so dass jetzt auch
verschiedene Sondervermögen in den
Ländern betroffen sein könnten und es
ist natürlich völlig richtig dass die
Bundesregierung jetzt dafür sorgen
sollte diese Probleme zu adressieren die
aus dem Urteil folgen auch wenn das
Urteil sich nicht direkt auf den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond bezieht
weil natürlich möchte man jetzt nicht
wieder eine Situation der Unsicherheit
kreieren sondern jetzt muss man wirklich
aufräumen also jetzt haben wir
Unsicherheit aber das was jetzt
passieren muss und eine Aufarbeitung
ja
wir Situation haben der man sich darauf
verlassen kann was finanzpolitisch
entschieden wird Herr weil wer hat's
verhindert das kann ich ihn nicht sagen
aber es wäre in der es wä in der Tat ich
bin ja nicht Teil der
regierungsdiskussion der internen aber
richtig wäre man hätte natürlich für 23
auch eine Notlage beschließen können was
sch nicht im Nachhinein betrachtet wäre
das auch wesentlich klüger gewesen nur
das eigentliche Dilemma hätte das auch
nicht gelöst denn was das
Bundesverfassungsgericht wirklich mit
seiner Entscheidung wähentlich oder
nicht schonungslos offenlegt ist eine
echte Schwachstelle der SCH
Schuldenbremse wir haben robert hat am
Anfang gesagt jetzt eine Phase von
manchen Jahren ich sag mal von 10 Jahren
wo wirklich an den unterschiedlichsten
Stellen viel passieren muss viel
investiert werden muss und wir können
nicht von jahr zu jah immer sagen so
jetzt haben wir aber die Notlage und
jetzt haben wir sie schon wieder und
jetzt haben wir sie zum dritten Mal das
Grundgesetz ist gibt im Moment noch
keine vernünftige Antwort auf die Frage
was machen wir mit einer Herausforderung
die nicht kurzfristig ist sondern die
eine mittelfristige ist und deswegen
vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr unbedingt
eine Notlage sondern mal eine
Entwicklungsphase in der sich unser Land
befindet und was ich mir wirklich
Wünsche ist wenn jetzt dieser ganze
Nebel sich verzogen hat äh dass dann die
vernünftigen Menschen mal zusammenkomen
und sich fragen was lernt uns das
eigentlich für eine sinnvolle
Ausgestaltung der Schuldenbremse so wie
sie jetzt ist ganz egal wer regiert
in diesen Zeiten in denen sich alles
wahnsinnig schnell ändert und alles
gleichzeitig ist es wenig praktikabel
Frau bowski auch an Sie die Frage wie
groß ist der Scherbenhaufen vor dem man
da jetzt steht und wer ist
verantwortlich dafür dass das so gemacht
worden ist na ja es legt natürlich noch
mal deutlich einen Konflikt den wir
schon lange Beobachten von Position
innerhalb der Ampel die nicht ohne
weiteres vereinbar sind oder man kann
auch sagen unvereinbar sind also die FDP
besteht auf hoher großer
Haushaltsdisziplin Einhaltung der SCH
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse
insbesondere ähm und SPD und Grüne mit
unterschiedlichen Schwerpunkten sagen
ähm es muss viel Geld in die Hand
genommen werden und investiert werden in
die Transformation der Wirtschaft und in
andere Dinge Hilfe für Verbraucher und
so weiter so und das ist ähm das war die
Ausgangslage ja auch schon in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen und das ist im
Grunde genommen dann hat man gesagt dann
macht man beides und das ist dann der
Versuch der Quadratur des Kreises die
bekanntermaßen nicht funktioniert oder
die nur funktioniert wenn man eine
umgehungskonstruktion wählt und so äh so
ist es passiert und
jetzt ist es hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht das mit sehr
klaren Worten auch in einer
ähm ja nicht nur in sehr klaren Worten
sondern auch ohne jegliche
Übergangsfristen also die Leute die die
gesagt haben ganz direkt kann auch ein
sehr hartes sehr nüchternes aber sehr n
und aber eben auch ohne jegliche
Übergangsfristen also die Menschen die
darauf geschaut haben und gesagt haben
das kann auch schiefgehen und ehrlich
gesagt innerhalb der Bundesregierung so
habe ich das wahrgenommen äh ist die
Zuversicht eigentlich gestiegen nach der
Eilentscheidung im vergangenen November
wo man was aber dann eben nur eine so
heißt es dann ja unter Juristen äh
abwegung gewesen ist also ist es
schlimmer wenn wenn die jetzt ausgesetzt
wird oder wenn Sie jetzt nicht
ausgesetzt wird also man guckt auf die
Folgen aber macht noch keine volle
Rechtsprüfung da erkehrte dann so eine
gewisse Zuversicht ein auch dieser diese
Hoffnung dass das Verfassungsgericht am
Ende auch politisch denkt und in dieser
gesamten Krisenlage jetzt nicht auch
noch der Bundesregierung die ja die
Grundlage wegziehen würde die
Geschäftsgrundlage eigentlich wegziehen
würde äh da war eine gewisse Zuversicht
da und das erklärt vielleicht auch warum
wir jetzt ja auch heute wieder hören
mussten es ist im Grunde also ich
befürworte das ja sehr dass jetzt über
eine Lösung nachgedacht wird aber es
wäre natürlich würde viel von
Verunsicherung wegnehmen wenn man jetzt
sagen würde ja wir haben mit diesem
Szenario zumindest gerechnet wir haben
gehofft dass es anders kommt wir haben
damit wir mussten damit rechnen und
deswegen ist unser Plan jetzt XY Z so
das ist natürlich jetzt äh nicht nicht
hilfreich zur Frage wer wer hat es aus
sich ausgedacht ich war ja auch nicht
dabei ich habe natürlich verschiedene
Geschichten gehört und die sind wie in
Berlin alle Geschichten immer Interessen
geleitet deswegen weiß ich nicht genau
was die Wahrheit ist aber es war wohl so
dass das Finanzministerium das ja
innerhalb der koalitionsverhandlung noch
unter Olaf Scholz geführt wurde mit dem
Staatssekretär
versucht hatte aus diesen unvereinbaren
Position diese Idee zu entwickeln so war
jetzt die Geschichte die ich am am
häufigsten gehört habe ob sie das wahrer
mach weiß ich nicht aber dass dann am
Ende die SPD gesagt hat so das ist jetzt
die Idee mit der vielleicht alle leben
können und haben alle gesagt ja und den
Koalitionsvertrag unterschrieben so
Herbeck wird war dabei der wird es
sagen können aber er hat ja gesagt er
will es nicht sagen insofern kommen wir
wahrscheinlich an der Stelle jetzt nicht
weiter Herbeck die große Frage wie
geht's jetzt weiter der Blick nach vorne
wo sparen wir wie machen wir das jetzt
Friedrich Merz schlägt vor wir sollten
jetzt mal beim Thema soziales Bürgergeld
und so weiter einsparen wie finden sie
das Kindergrundsicherung
im Moment kommen wir gerade aus einer
Phase raus die vielen Menschen sehr viel
zugemutet hat die hohe Inflation die
hohen Preise für Lebensmittel für
Energie für alle Konsumgüter also sehr
viele Menschen sind in dem letzten Jahr
ärmer geworden deswegen gibt es
natürlich auch einen Grund jetzt nicht
im sozialen Bereich den Druck noch
einmal zu erhöhen die Spannung im Land
die gesellschaftliche die demokratische
sie ist ja hoch genug ist ja nicht so
dass wir den die stabilste Phase dieser
Republik gerade erleben sondern ganz im
Gegenteil es gibt hohe Unsicherheit die
gesellschaftliche Stimmung ist aufgeraut
fast porös das muss man eben auch
mitbedenken und
so geht es mit allen Vorschlägen die ich
im Moment lese und höre und was ich so
mitbekomme wenn man Gelder erhöhen will
Steuern erhöhen will erhöht man damit
wahrscheinlich auch die Kosten für
irgendwelche Produkte oder man
schwiänert die Ausgaben seit also treibt
die Inflation noch einmal an oder
vermindert die Kaufkraft und insofern
ist das jetzt nicht ganz einfach aus
dieser aus dieser widersprüchlichen
Aufgabe die uns ja gestellt ist ich
wiederhole es noch mal auch letztlich
verfassungsgerichtlich gestellt ist
nämlich den Klimaschutz ernst zu nehmen
und gleichzeitig die Schuldenbremse
penibel einzuhalten eine eine neue
Lösung zu finden und erlauben Sie mir
noch mal Herr LZ dass ich mich an diesen
Spekulationen nicht beteiligen möchte
jetzt muss die Regierung das hat ja
frauobowski gerade gesagt Lösung
präsentieren und die präsentieren wir am
besten indem wir uns hinter den Kulissen
abstimmen und dann sie nach außen
darstellen weil ich aber trotzdem heute
die Chance habe schließen Sie
Steuererhöhungen
aus noch einmal das ist jetzt alles
Spekulation und ich möchte mich daran
gerne nicht beteiligen aber sie
schließen sie nicht
aus das ist unfair her LZ wenn sie jetzt
sagen ich möchte mich dazu nicht äußern
aha dann habe habe ich eine eine
Äußerung gehört das ist ist jetzt
tatsächlich eine sensible Phase ich
würde es vielleicht mal so formulieren
sie ist so sensibel dass ich es sehr
begrüßen würde wenn alle demokratischen
Parteien und Politikerinnen und
Politiker sich jetzt helfen würden
unterhaken und
gute Ideen zur Lösung beisteuern würden
es ist keine Phase auch wenn man recht
bekommen hat vor dem vor dem Gericht das
hat ja die Union also die Opposition die
uns gegen uns geklagt ist wo man sich wo
man darüber frohocken kann da sind zu
viele Menschen zu viele Schicksale jetzt
sehr unmittelbar davon betroffen und
deswegen müssen wir alle die das
Interesse haben dass das Land stabil in
die Zukunft geführt wird und
gesellschaftlicher Frieden erhalten und
vielleicht wieder erstmal hergestellt
wird dafür arbeiten dass wir jetzt gute
Lösung finden und die finden wir nicht
indem wir uns gegenseitig über talksh
oder Medien belehen was alles gehen
würde oder nicht gehen kann okay ich
entnehme dem sie schließen tatsächlich
nichts aus und ich kann mir das auch
vorstellen dass man nichts ausschließt
im Moment würd sie trotzdem gerne fragen
weil sie dies gesellschaftliche Klima
jetzt auch schon zum zweiten mal
ansprechen auch dieses frocken von
Friedrich märz das da zu vernehmen war
auch in der Union ganz
grundsätzlich sie haben dieser Tage bei
den Kollegen im Deutschlandfunk ich
glaube Montag war es ein ein ziemlich
wütendes Interview zu dem Thema gegeben
und
haben sich sozusagen darüber beklagt was
ihn da Friedrich März angetan hat mit
dieser Klage wie ist ihr Verhältnis im
Moment
nein die vokabelen sind nicht ganz
richtig weder ist mir was angetan worden
noch würde ich äh Beschreibung wie Täter
oder Opfer für richtig finden niemand
der vor Gericht sein Recht einklagt oder
recht überprüfen lässt ist ein Täter das
ist wie völlig falsche Vokabel und
niemand also jedenfalls nicht die
Bundesregierung sollte sich in eine
Opferrolle reindenken oder
reinfühlen in der Tat was ich nicht
angemessen finde so möchte ich sagen ist
der Umgang mit dem Urteil da war
manchmal so ein figznerer Übermut und
wenn man sozusagen einen politischen
Sieg oder einen Punktsieg erringt dann
soll man sich darüber meintweggen freuen
das kann man keinem nehmen und auch
keinem verwehren aber man muss sich
schon klar machen und das fehlt dir
vielleicht in der ersten Reaktion auf
das Urteil was damit sich verbindet und
es ist ja manchmal hilfreich sich in die
Situation der anderen zu versetzen also
ja es könnte hätte auch sein können dass
jemand also die Grünen die FDP oder die
SPD in der Opposition dagegen geklagt
hätte es hätte aber auch sein können
dass die Union eine ähnliche Lage jetzt
hat oder bewältigen müsste und wie würde
sie damit umgehen und man sieht es in
den Bundesländern das sind ja auch ich
rede immer von der Union das ist glaube
ich sehr ungenau es gibt die Union in
Berlin und es gibt Ministerpräsidenten
und wirtschaftsministerkollegen in den
Bundesländern die hoch alarmiert sind
die hoch besorgt sind die versuchen
jetzt ebenfalls eine Lösung zu bekommen
Frau Grimm hat es gerade Anges sprochen
auch
Länderhaushalte haben ähnliche
Konstrukte gewählt die jetzt
möglicherweise ebenfalls nicht mehr zur
Verfügung stehen also da wo die
Verantwortung ausgeübt wird da ist die
Besorgnis groß vor dieser Situation und
Verantwortung kann man ja auch in der
Opposition ausüben deswegen würde ich
mich freuen wenn wir einen Modus finden
würden wo wir uns
gegenseitig helfen oder stützen und ich
würde auch darauf wetten dass bei einem
nächsten Wahlkampf die Menschen in
Deutschland klug genug und
wahrscheinlich auch lösungsorientiert
genug sind dass sie diejenigen die jetzt
die Lösung präsentieren wählen egal ob
Opposition oder Regierung diese wettete
müssen wir doch eingehen dass wir nicht
das Destruktive in Deutschland politisch
belohnen sondern das konstruktive und an
der an dem Punkt sind wir jetzt zum
Abschluss noch noch zwei Fragen ein Mann
aus ihrer eigenen Partei Jürgen trtin
sagt auch ich hätte gegen diesen
Haushalt geklagt wenn ich in der
Opposition gewesen wäre haben sie ihn
schon
angerufen nee habe ich nicht aber es ist
auch also wahrscheinlich meint jür trtin
es macht Sinn sich in die Rolle des
anderen zu versetzen und Politik ist
manchmal und das ist nicht die schönste
Seite der Politik
fast wie ein Spiel man probiert was man
kann gegenüber der anderen Seite den
anderen eins
auszuwischen irgendwie ist das ein Teil
der Welt in der auch ich politisch
unterwegs bin und dann freut man sich
über die Schlagzeile vielleicht ein
Gerichtsurteil und so weiter und Jürgen
ich habe das nicht gelesen in gänz das
Zitat habe ich gesehen hat vielleicht
sagen wollen na ja jetzt bevor man sich
ärgert über die anderen überlegt euch
mal was wir gemacht hätten aber der
umkehrstluss ist eben auch richtig dass
ich die anderen wenn ich so reden darf
die die Opposition im Deutschen
Bundestag die demokratische Opposition
sicherlich fragen sollte wie kommen wir
da jetzt raus also dass wir ein Stück
weit vielleicht die die Rolle von Zorn
und Herme jetzt mal verlassen und
ernsthaft daran arbeiten eine gan GZ
schwierige Situation zu bestehen und zu
bewältigen und noch einmal die Situation
ja sie ist natürlich auch für die
ampelregierung schwierig aber es ist
nicht in allererster Linie ein Problem
einer Regierung sondern es ist ein
objektives Problem dass Deutschland
nachdem ihm die Hälfte seiner
gasinfrastruktur und Lieferung
weggebrochen ist nachdem wir in einer
anderen Welt uns wiederfinden als noch
der Koalitionsvertrag sie vorgefunden
hatte als wir ihn geschlossen haben weil
die Amerikaner ein riesiges
subvenstionsprogramm aufgelegt haben
dass wir damals noch gar nicht kannten
weil die der Krieg in der Ukraine
fortdauert und wie die Ukraine
unterstützen müssen und wollen mit
milliardenzahlung die ebenfalls nicht
vorgesehen waren dass wir in dieser Welt
bestehen müssen ist ja eine objektive
Herausforderung jede Regierung würde
sich ihrstellen müssen und mit dieser
Haltung jede Regierung kommt man
vielleicht auch in eine in eine
Gesprächssituation dass man die im
Moment so verkeilten und schwer
vorstellbaren Lösungen dann doch möglich
war wollte gerade sagen also noch
abschließend noch mal gefragt weil sie
das gerade andeuten das heißt da haben
sie ja ganz ganz schwierige Gespräche
mit Christian Lindner vor sich die FDP
frlockt ja auch ihre eigene Regierung
verlockt oder der Teil ihrer Regierung
frlockt sozusagen indem man sagt Gott
sei Dank ist das jetzt mal gerade
gerückt und diese Subventionitis sage
ich jetzt mit meinen Worten die muss mal
aufhören wir müssen jetzt mal ernsthaft
mit weniger Geld bessere Politik machen
Sie sie sie sind der andere Teil der
dafür steht dass man sagt die ganze Welt
subventioniert und ob uns das gefällt
oder nicht wir müssen diesen Wettlauf in
irgendeiner Form der uns von außen
aufgedrängt wird den müssen wir
irgendwie mitlaufen weil wir ansonsten
als wichtiges Industrieland irgendwann
uns ganz hinten einreihen
müssen also erst einmal möchte ich sagen
dass ich Christian Lindner häufig treffe
und sehe und ihn alles andere als
verlockend wahrnehme sondern tatsächlich
hochkonzentriert in der
Situation her viele
and alle die wissen dass es um wirklich
viel geht so und zweitens
es gibt um für Subvention im Kern zwei
Gründe einmal Techniken oder oder oder
Produkte marktfähig zu machen die es
noch nicht sind also die Gesellschaft
hat sich entschieden
ich weiß nicht klimaneutral Auto zu
fahren aber die Autos die E-Autos sind
noch teurer niemand würde sie kaufen
also subventionieren wir sie das ist
finde ich ein guter Grund für Subvention
solange bis sie marktgängig sind man
kann das auch anders machen über höhere
CO2 Preise aber auch da stößt man
irgendwann an eine gesellschaftliche
Grenze weil die dann ja von denjenigen
die sich nicht gleich neues Auto kaufen
können um Beispiel zu bleiben gezahlt
werden müssen und dann gibt es einen
eigentlich schlechten Grund für
Subvention der eben auch nicht im
Lehrbuch für Ökonomie steht dass wir das
Staaten sich nicht nur
marktwirtschaftlich und ökonomisch
Verhalten sondern dass sie Markt
Wirtschaft und und und und und
Wirtschaftspolitik machtpolitisch
Aufladen interessenspolitisch Aufladen
versuchen Einfluss zu gewinnen und in
dieser Situation befinden wir uns meiner
Auffassung nach das heißt sie werden
Frau Grimm ist ja da und wir reden
häufig darüber sie werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich in der nächsten Sendung
verschiedene Ökonomen hören aber die
Trennlinie in der Debatte ist im Grunde
die Einschätzung ob man
Wirtschaftspolitik als reine Lehre der
Marktwirtschaft denkt oder auch Sie als
politisch
geladene Sphäre denkt ein letztes
Beispiel wir um mal etwas vielleicht
neutraleres zu nehmen wir haben eine
hohe Abhängigkeit von Rohstoffen in
verschiedenen Bereichen und diese
Rohstoffe kommen ganz häufig aus China
also wir sind bei bestimmten kritischen
Produkten von China abhängig die
Rohstoffe die aus China kommen sind
günstiger als würden wir sie in Europa
herstellen oder aus den Minen holen oder
aus Südamerika oder Afrika sonst würden
wir es ja tun jetzt ist die Frage Frage
ist es klug so eine hohe Abhängigkeit zu
haben ökonomisch macht man sagen ja das
kann Klug sein und wenn wir sie nicht
von China haben dann haben sie sie
vielleicht von anderen Ländern aber
Abhängigkeiten sind nicht weiter
tragisch denn die Märkte werden immer
funktionieren und das Angebot wenn es
günstig ist ist das bessere Angebot es
mag aber auch und ich ma kein h daraus
das ist dann auch meine Analyse eine
Meinung geben die sagen eine 100%entige
Abhängigkeit auch eine 80 oder
90przentige Abhängigkeit in bestimmten
Bereichen ist zu hoch wir brauchen
eigene Verfügbarkeit zumindestens eigene
eigene Kenntnisse wie wir im
Zweifelsfall unsere eigenen Produktion
hochskaliieren können das ist aber im
Kern kein ökonomisches Argument sondern
ein
wirtschaftssicherheitsargument und auch
in dieser Phase befinden wir uns ich
würde fast sagen
unvorhergesehenerweise nach dem
ukrainekrieg oder dem russischen Angriff
auf die Ukraine haben wir gesehen dass
wird das Energiepolitik hoch hoch
machtpolitisch aufgeladen ist und das
gleiche gilt für Rohstoffe meiner
Ansicht nach oder für kritische
Komponenten wie Halbleiter und so weiter
und deswegen ist die die die
Dringlichkeit der Situation neben all
dem was wir schon besesprochen haben
Arbeitsplätze strukturbrüche Wohlstand
schaffen Klimaneutralität schaffen
zusätzlich noch eine Frage von wie
robust stellt sich das Land und der
Kontinent in dieser in dieser
schwierigen Phase auf und auch da haben
wir jetzt eine deutliche Schwächung und
noch einmal ich appelliere sozusagen an
alle die mithelfen wollen dass das Land
die Menschen in diesem Land und die
Unternehmen in diesem Land hier gut
durchkommen diese Situation ernst zu
nehmen und bei der Lösung mitzuarbeiten
und dann appelliere ich am Ende oder
hoffe ich ist im Grunde eine Wette
darauf dass in Deutschland die
Politikerinnen und Politiker belohnt
werden die eine Lösung herstellen wollen
und keine Lösung verhindern und wenn wir
das diese Wette nicht mehr gewinnen
können dann wird es ganz ganz schwierig
aber wir werden sie gewinnen das ist ein
gutes Schlusswort ich ich danke ihn sehr
dass ich d dem heute gestellt haben weiß
dass Sie wenig Zeit haben noch mit der
Bitte um ja oder nein sind sie weiterhin
für die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse ja
oder
nein für diese Legislatur ist die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse also die
Einhaltung das ist ja klar die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse sagt das
Verfassungsgericht ist Verfassungsnorm
die muss eingehalten werden die Frage
die Stefan weil aufgeworfen hat ist ist
die Schuldenbremse klug genug
konstruiert für diese Situation also
kann man sie
stärker in machen indem man sie anders
macht und das wäre meine persönliche
Meinung ja das kann man tun es geht mir
nicht darum die Schulden oder ginge mir
nicht darum die Schuldenbremse
abzuschaffen sondern sie auszurichten
auf die Erfordernisse unserer Zeit
meiner Ansicht nach ist das eine
Stärkung aber wir haben im
Koalitionsvertrag anderes verabredet
deswegen werden wir eine Lösung für
dieses Problem nach den Regeln des
Koalitionsvertrags nur in dem Rahmen
finden den wir uns selbst jetzt gegeben
haben und äh daran arbeite ich jetzt
wenn ich aus dieser Sendung rausgehe